hey guys justin here Mary Jess Danny all
of the other good hosts are not
available so i guess i'm filling in
today for your Wednesday July thirteenth
and the biggest news in gaming hey did
you remember all of those big Microsoft
leaks during e3 this year well they're
still happening a whole bunch of info
about some xbox one s models leaked
earlier today Microsoft will release
special edition Xbox one s models
steamed around Gears of War for and halo
5 guardians according to a new leaked
images of the unannounced consoles
popped up online this week courtesy of
Twitter user at ECAM GAF for the gears
of war console the franchise's famous
crimson omen is seen on the two
terabytes system itself alongside what
looks like a blood splatter in the
corner the xbox one controller sports a
similar design the bundle also
reportedly comes with a digital copy of
the one hundred dollar Gears of War for
ultimate edition which includes the game
season pass and other digital items
regarding the rumored halo 5 1 terabyte
Xbox one s the image doesn't look all
that special as it's the normal white
system and controller presumably with a
copy of the game bundled then there's no
word yet on pricing or a release date
the xbox one s starts its rollout in
august though it appears only the most
expensive version of the system will be
available that moving over to a Sony
console exclusive Metal Gear Solid
creator Hideo Kojima has said that he
thinks his new game death stranding is
going to be one of his best ever during
a keynote address at the develop
conference Kojima went on to say that
for his past games he's had to make
compromises in some areas to get his
projects out the door this apparently
won't be the case with his new game so
far when I've been making games I've had
to give up on something or at least
compromise on something in order to get
things done Kojima explained but this
time working with mark Cerny and
bringing the state-of-the-art
technologies will get around that usual
problem I'm very confident that we're
working towards something completely new
and that no one has seen so far this
will be my best work so far I'm very
confident about that he didn't specify
how he'll surpass the moment in Metal
Gear Solid 4 when you learn that liquid
ocelot isn't being mind controlled by
his implant at hand and has instead been
under self-induced hypnosis for the last
several years
you live in europe and are you afraid of
being too productive in your day-to-day
life don't worry Pokemon go is coming
out now in Europe and select country
continuing its worldwide expansion into
global domination Pokemon go released in
germany today the game's first European
territory the hugely popular mobile game
arrived in Australia and New Zealand
last week before coming to the United
States last wednesday july six its
release in Europe could have come sooner
it seems after Pokemon goes launched
last week the server struggled likely
due in parts of the game's massive
popularity as a result developer niantic
labs announced that it had paused the
games international release a report
earlier this week said Pokemon go would
be released in europe as well as Japan
and other Asian regions within a few
days but it remains to be seen when
other European countries will get to
play pokemon go we'll report back with
more information as it becomes available
and that's all the news for today stop
by gamespot for even more news and to
stay up to date on the latest in gaming
hopefully you won't have to put up with
me again tomorrow